right now Marvel Studios and Disney in
general are in a state of let's call it
repairment unfortunately although both
Marvel and Disney have had some good
movies and good shows come out their
numbers overall either their streaming
numbers on Disney Plus or the box office
numbers have been pretty bad recently
and overall there has been a large chunk
of people who have been losing interest
in a lot of their projects it's
unfortunate but the good news is they
know this and Bob Iger the CEO of Disney
has spoken up about this a lot recently
he's done several interviews where he's
addressed several different things
including the failure of the Marvels
which unfortunately has the lowest box
office numbers in history for Marvel
Studios and here's what's really
interesting about this Disney and
recently Marvel Studios have been really
accused of agenda pushing pushing their
own messages trying to force their
opinion on how they feel on the public
through their movies and shows and
essentially Bob Iger has kind of agreed
in a recent interview he stated that
creators at Disney which does also
include Marvel Studios have lost sight
of what their number one objective needs
to be and in the interview he
specifically States it's not about
messages basically admitting yes in
their projects they push messages and
they have lost sight of what really they
should be focusing on and that is just
good storytelling So today we're going
to break down what he said in recent
interviews and talk about what this
means for the future of Marvel Studios
and Disney and how Bob Iger is trying to
and I quote here return to Our Roots
which could be great news for Marvel and
Disney fans and if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
Marvel news and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
Wi A PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items we pick a
winner at the end of each month and the
winner gets to pick one item so let's
first acknowledge that Bob Iger
acknowledges that there are many
different factors that have led to sort
of bad quality content from both Marvel
and Disney which of course has led to
less interest in the franchises right
away it's really good that they're
acknowledging this because that means
they can fix it or at least attempt to
and I believe after watching these
interviews and reading about them they
are heading in the right direction now
even though a lot of people have
seemingly enjoyed the Marvels the film
unfortunately it was a box office
disaster for Marvel and in an interview
via The Verge Bob Iger talked about why
the sequel to The 2019 Captain Marvel
film which did over a billion doll
failed Bob Iger said this and this all
is going to ultimately tie in together
of what Marvel studios's new plan is
which of course we'll get to but Bob
Iger said this the Marvels was shot
during Co and there wasn't enough
supervision on set from Executives now
this is a big part and keep this in mind
cuz we're going to circle back to this
supervision on set from Executives now
as far as being shot during Co they did
a lot of re-shoot and sure Co affected
some things but they had enough time to
fix whatever they thought was wrong and
which they clearly tried to do because
because they did a ton of re-shoot I
think the problem here was really more
of the supervision and the writing and
storytelling which Bob Iger addressed in
another interview and this was during
the times annual dealbook Summit in New
York City and this was less than a week
ago when he said this during the summit
he said that he will no longer tolerate
his company's partners and creative team
prioritizing messaging over storytelling
he says creators lost sight of what
their number one objective needed to be
we have have to entertain first it's not
about messages this is what I actually
said in a video not too long ago was the
main problem for Marvel Studios right
now the writing they need to write
better stories don't get me wrong I'm
all for a positive message but these
movies are supposed to entertain us and
for a lot of us we look to these to kind
of Escape just get lost in an awesome
superhero film yes some can be deep and
some could have great meaning and
messages behind them but the story still
needs to be good especially if you want
that message to to come across because
if the movie is bad the message might
not be cared about so much and sometimes
really trying to force a message can
make the movie actually bad which is
what Bob Iger is basically stating here
and he goes on to say some pretty
interesting things and make pretty
interesting points he said and I quote
we have entertained with values and with
having a positive impact on the world in
many different ways black panther is a
great example of that I like being able
to entertain if you can Infuse it with
positive messages and have a good impact
on the world
fantastic but that should not be the
objective when I came back what I have
really tried to do is return to Our
Roots he went on to say I've worked hard
since I've been back to reminding the
creative Community who are our partners
and our employees that that's the
objective and I don't really want to
tolerate the opposite now it's
interesting that Bob Iger said they're
going to go back to their Roots When I
hear him say this phrase I think about
Snow White it's the best example that I
could think of at the time we have the
classic original Snow White it's a
classic for a reason it's loved by
millions of people for a reason and then
you have the Remake liveaction that
they're doing now in which they said
Snow White is not going to need the help
of a prince she's not going to be in
love she's not going to need the help of
the man they are basically scrapping the
entire story and they've gotten a ton of
backlash against that because why well
the original Snow White story is a
cherished classic in this they are
trying to push a message over
storytelling and don't get me wrong
there's nothing wrong with women being
independent and strong however you are
messing with a classic that people love
and you're doing it specifically to push
your own message I think this is a
pretty good example of what Bob Iger is
talking about they have to focus on
storytelling first over the message
first make a great story then work in a
really good positive message and that
still could be a problem on its own
because of course one thing that
resonates with somebody in a positive
way could end up resonating with
somebody in a negative way but
unfortunately that's just life but if
you focus on writing a good story then
perhaps some of these films that haven't
been so good lately due to a lack of a
really good story could be awesome films
and the Marvels is really a perfect
example there are many parts of the
Marvels that I really enjoyed and I was
actually really looking forward to the
movie I like Brie Larsson I liked the
entire cast really and I thought Captain
Marvel in this film was a lot more
relatable than she was in the first
however sadly the plot just wasn't there
for me and the story was just kind of of
all over the place which made me walk
out of the theater thinking that it
wasn't such a good film if the overall
storytelling of the movie would have
been better it could have been a great
movie but sadly it wasn't there so Bob
buer talking about how they're going to
go back to their roots and start
focusing more on good storytelling is
really good news he also did reiterate
that they have essentially just produced
way too much content he was specifically
speaking of Marvel Studios 2 when he
stated that the volume of content
created by Marvel Studios over the past
couple of years has made it difficult to
maintain quality and he has stated that
Marvel Studios is looking to produce
less content in the future now producing
too much content definitely hurt Marvel
Studios it hurt them in a lot of
different places and the storytelling is
definitely one place that got severely
affected and the fact that they were
doing so much meant circling back to
what Bob Iger originally said less
overall supervision from Executives it
used to be that Kevin fuggy would be on
every project Hands-On supervising but
since Disney plus came out they decided
to do more movies and a lot of shows per
year that obviously stretched him pretty
thin it stretched all the executives
pretty thin and they also at the same
time brought in some new writers and new
storytellers and new directors all that
didn't necessarily have a lot of
experience so new combined with lack of
supervision from the people who know
what they're doing in the MCU led to an
overall quality decrease but again the
great thing is Bob Iger knows this and
Kevin feige knows this as well and
getting back to the roots as far as
Marvel is concerned hope hopefully that
means they're going to go back to their
Roots which was Phase 1 Phase 2 and
phase three a time where they made
really awesome films that connected to
other films and ultimately led to these
amazing characters who had really good
stories coming together for an even
bigger story that they all shared
together so I think Disney and Marvel
are on the right track hopefully that
means the quality will increase and
we'll have some awesome movies and shows
coming out really soon but go ahead and
let me know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below what do you
think will this help please don't forget
to like the video And subscribe to stay
up to date on all things relating to the
MCU you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof
woof